the thing is his time is go our
economies go down we might go into a
depression
the worldwide Frances had very big
trouble Germany is okay England's in big
trouble China's in trouble so if we go
that we go to a worldwide depression and
might take ten years you know to come
out of it but during these times this is
the best time I have made more money in
the last three years than ever before in
my life I bought five golf courses last
year they're giving them away but you
have to know how to operate them ethic
be an entrepreneur this Japanese company
had it and they asked me if I want to
buy it but five years ago for 260
million I said does it make sense you
know it doesn't make sense at 260
million so they told me I didn't know
what I was doing this goodbye and that
one year ago that the Citibank called up
and says you want lost golf courses and
they gave me the money to buy him in
twice 1975 I came out with this product
and we're extremely successful but we
kept running out of money the more
successful we got the more we ran out of
money that's when I went to my Rich Dad
I tried to borrow $100,000 and he chewed
me out he says why would I invest in a
dumb product when you have a bad
business that's when he began teach me
the next level of my entrepreneurial
education it's not about the product
it's about how to design a business that
doesn't need me to keep raising capital
in other words how do you design a
business that keeps raising money
automatically the day that Rich Dad
company is cash-rich cash keeps pouring
in because the ability to raise money
constantly was designed into the
business well many times people to have
a great product but their legal is
really bad or this communication systems
are bad or their internal order
processing is a bad well the
manufacturing is bad with a marketing
spent and they don't want to have bad
cash flow management you just watched
two amazing clips of Robert Kiyosaki
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you